el acuerdo se consideró un gran logro en
2015 pero cinco años después son pocos
los que lo respetan las temperaturas
siguen en aumento la amazonía tiene
récords de deforestación etcétera como
lograr un compromiso real
efectivamente no hay mucho que celebrar
es una pena el secretario de naciones
unidas ha mencionado que el kobe 19
tiene vacuna pero el planeta no tiene y
que estamos en una pelea con el planeta
que necesitamos hacer una paz con el
mundo entero y que las emisiones van en
aumento lamentablemente es si es que las
naciones no se comprometen efectivamente
a bajar un 6% en el uso de combustibles
fósiles cada año hasta el 2030
lamentablemente no llegaremos a la meta
de cumplir carbono neutralidad 2050 con
las consecuencias que esto conlleva una
consecuencia catastrófica estamos viendo
ya los efectos del cambio climático en
temperaturas que se han registrado como
las más altas en la historia de la
humanidad y qué
si vamos en este tránsito simplemente
estaríamos aumentando de 3 a 5 grados
celsius la temperatura del planeta no
estamos cumpliendo con los acuerdos este
año es crucial este fin de semana
justamente se ha realizado una cumbre
ambiental mundial liderada por francia y
por el reino unido- para fortalecer los
acuerdos y llamar a especialmente los
países desarrollados a que cumplan con
lo que como se comprometieron esto habrá
que dar cuenta habrá que no se queden en
lindos anuncios sino que sean
contabilizados de efectivamente cómo van
a bajar estas emisiones y cómo van a
entregar la plata a los países más
desarrollados que son los que más
afectados están siendo por los efectos
de cambio climático veronica al ser un
pacto que nació en europa parece muy
lejano de américa latina pero como
avanzado el compromiso en esta región
bueno efectivamente américa latina es
una de las regiones que menos contribuye
al cambio climático sin embargo tenemos
altas tasas de deforestación todavía
estamos en procesos de recuperación
económica desde hace mucho tiempo y
significa que pasamos por subsidios de
combustibles fósiles gasolina diésel y
no vemos con grandes perspectivas sino
excepto algunos ejemplos el cambio hacia
unas energías renovables esto es muy
importante porque por ejemplo y si es
que 22 ciudades de latinoamérica
cambiaría en ya de combustibles fósiles
por su transporte mucho más limpio
eléctrico o cualquier tecnología
estaríamos hablando de que se estaría
ahorrando 64 mil millones de dólares en
el uso y subsidio de combustibles
fósiles y además estaríamos
reduciendo la tasa de mortalidad de
muerte prematura por contaminación
ambiental de 19 mil millones hacia
realmente la mitad no entonces estamos
estamos hablando de que no está claro
todavía una política regional de un
cambio cuantitativo y sustancial hacia
energías renovables